each year the most dazzlingly dallona
have gathered to glisten and meanwhile
taking part in the trans-pacific
region's most luxurious opulent and
simply fabulous event
welcome to the 22nd annual asia-pacific
Economic Cooperation summit red carpet
live we are covering the singular story
that matters most of all I'm speaking of
course to the tradition of world leaders
we're in the host countries visually
stunning ceremonial garb and this year a
major controversy has already erupted on
day one involving China's President Xi
Jinping russia's President Vladimir
Putin and US President Barack Obama
that's right the three most powerful
leaders here committed the most ghastly
fashion faux-pas they showed up wearing
identical outfits you can almost hear
President Z say to President Putin well
one of us is gonna have to change and
then President Obama shows up in the
same thing
talk about getting full purple handed
it's an open secret amongst the
politicos and fashionista the like that
the American president doesn't
particularly enjoy the pageantry of
Asian summitry so much so that last year
he sent almost president John Kerry to
take his place look at those eyes you
can almost see him thinking man I was so
close to go into seven more of these an
actual president who relished the
ceremonial APEC photo op was Bill
Clinton who inaugurated the summit in
1993 the next year in Bogor Indonesia he
displayed the stylistic audacity of Lady
gaga in a meat dress Trias later in 1997
in Vancouver
it was the visiting leaders of the Asian
countries who had to adopt the apparel
of the West boy they probably looked
silly back home dashing as Bill Clinton
was his successor embraced the APEC
fashion ritual with even more
unrestrained Gustin
take a look at george w bush in lima in
2008 have you ever seen a gringo where a
Peruvian poncho with such panache and
check out those pajamas and that smile
whatever happened to that guy when the
APEC leaders wake up tomorrow here in
Beijing they'll take part in another
ceremony a plenary session and a family
photo he is hoping this time they won't
be wearing the same thing John